taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like
two foods gonna fight but only one food
can be right taste buds man yeah they're
coming to the mic i'm talking tonight
[Music]
i get used to saying that i like it the
taste buds podcast yeah i'm sal
i'm joe look at it the signs are right
here
there's the sign it's a beautiful sign
it's
our sign yeah it's our sign nobody else
can take that sign
uh we've got a lot to cover today yeah
we're coming in hard off last week where
we brought up the hoagie challenge and
if you were able to eat
hoagie a hoagie every day for one
calendar year
i quickly reduced it to two months then
maybe even one month because i thought
you were off your john rocker
for doing that and we sat down today and
i said well today's the day we need to
tell the audience
uh we have to talk about this because we
have to present to them
what the rules of the hoagie challenge
are and you cut me off in the middle of
saying that and you went i'm not doing
[Laughter]
that
i think people would have been excited
you didn't even want to do like a
truncated like
like 30 day the 30 day hoagie challenge
30 day i would do
i'm not doing three months i'm not doing
six months i'm not doing a year
here's why two reasons the first is
the same so yeah it's insane three
reasons the first is insane
yeah the second is uh i
i don't remember what his name is i
apologize sir
i think it was a guy that said this to
me but you might have saved my life
somebody tweeted at me and he just goes
please don't do this
you will change your arteries forever
there's no coming back from this and i
was like
well we suspected that well i didn't it
really just hit me the way he said it
because that's like a plea
is there any way to just go back right
now and just play
the two three second clip of him last
week confidently being like
i'll lead to okay i will i will
said it like you never care in the world
i didn't and now you get one
stranger whose name you don't remember
that says do not do this it will change
your life forever
it sounds like the same guy that writes
the emails that like send this to ten
friends within five minutes no no
your dog will die i'll do the hoagie
challenge i'll eat a hoagie every day
for a year
no you can't do that you think i can't
do it
i know that you can't do that why
because you're not
understanding what that means you're
gonna have a hoagie 365 days
in a row yeah how much i believe in the
house you would transform
yourself i mean
i i want to give you a chance to back to
bp back out of this
he it just uh he said it in a way
where i was like he's right i'm 43 i
could do
irreversible damage to my body like i
didn't think about that
yeah i didn't think of it like that i
thought of it like i said it to your
face i said
you can't eat that kind of processed
meat for that long
what do you think about it we spoke
about it but everybody see now i'm
thinking about i could do it because
no because people eat lunch meat every
day
yeah i said that i said it's not every
day
at large people eat lunch meat every day
but no one person you knows
eats lunch meat every day right uh
eating deli meats every day gives you
plenty of body fueling protein since a
two ounce portion of turkey breast deli
meat posts
approximately 13 grams of protein as
noted by live strong
a single sandwich could put you well on
your way to attaining that daily
consumption goal uh i don't know this is
sounding like it's pushing me to do it
i mean that's the thing if four of the
days it was
a turkey wait hold on eating more
typical serving of 50 grams of processed
meat a day would increase the risk of
colorectal cancer by 18
unprocessed red meat by comparisons
increases cancer risk
only at amounts greater than 100 grams a
day how much meat is a hundred grams
that's a good question i don't really
remember grams
uh a hundred grams grams to ounces
just put 100 grams grams to ounces
calculator okay
all right now let's put in uh eight
ounces that's half a pound
you're doing it backwards okay so eight
ounces is half no this helps me now do
four okay quarter pound of meat on your
sandwich is dangerous
jesus go down to two
that's one so you you can do like two
ounces at best that's not a lot of meat
no right i don't think about a petite
filet it's like eight ounces
and you're not even talking so you had a
petite filet a day which is what you
threw up there at first
it's more than double the recommended
allowable meats per day
if you don't want to increase your
colorectal cancer rate by more than 20
percent
so i gotta stop eating petit filets
every day yeah
i mean it must be true it's the first
thing that came up
where's your comfort zone lie let's get
this interesting would you do two months
two months of hoagies remember you could
have two and as i look at this i'm
thinking i would do it for one month
i feel like and we should do it no
matter what even if it's only a month i
would still love to see
30 pictures of hoagies uh
there's got to be a reward i'm not cause
here's the third reason why you want to
do it
seal what do you mean you want to know
here's the third reason why i don't want
to do it i think you get yourself in
trouble on these podcasts
when you start doing some of these
things because it starts to become like
you're at the mercy of the audience to
do like these stunts
to keep it going i mean you've got these
kids on youtube they're like
you know i'm gonna swallow a hundred
marbles today 100 marble challenges
it's like i don't want to get caught in
the stunt category and everybody gets
caught
that hundred marble challenge takes off
all of a sudden you're seeing like
jennifer garner doing 100
marble challenge right all the celebs if
we were to do it
would you do the ice bucket challenge
i've never done a challenge in my life
did you ever do you never did a
challenge in your life i would do
i would i would do it under the guise of
in theory i would never do the real
road rules wow that's hard to say [ __ ]
that's hard to do all right buddy
real world real world wrote can you say
it fast real world road rules challenge
i had to think through it yeah you did
that's tough real world
stop it's really making me sad real
world role rules challenge
real world roll room you know what my
my my top my mouth can't catch up to my
little i have a bad mouth
but you got bad mouths yeah i get
everything gets in the way
real world rules here's what i would
consider doing
i mean this and we're not going to
commit to it right now okay
but in an episode after not the next
episode the one after that we might be
able to commit to it
i would consider doing the 30 day hoagie
challenge
as long as it is under the guise of this
is a challenge we are starting and i am
the first person to do the challenge
that's what i mean of course
uh but i want a prize of some kind all
right
let's let's i want some kind of prize
sound off in the comments
be realistic here what would what would
be a really good thing
something that's attainable that joe
would give joe motivation
that you can't normally just get like
what would be what do you have an idea
what would you like it could be as
little as a six-inch hoagie
which is fair
that's fair that's a shorty at wawa yeah
i think the real question is what month
of your life
should it be okay maybe it's august for
my birthday you don't have to do it
by a month you do it as a start date and
then you go 30 days okay
but seven inch hoagie there's got to be
some
minimum cap on the hoagie i i
isn't a hoagie like a he piece of hero
bread it's usually like this big
it's they they vary in size a new york
deli hero bread
okay because if you go on a celebrity 10
inches then okay
i i just think six inches a little bit
cheating
12 that's wrong it is not at least 12
inches joey roses are eight inches
and they're plenty filling so this is
what i'm saying like eight inches 10
inches
okay okay all right somewhere in there
you got to post it every day
um
if i want i'm allowed to do a tuna
hoagie if i want
she's walking a lot of orders at us for
uh for a challenge that doesn't exist
saying i don't
it's not like i got to do salami every
day or something i don't
want you to get hurt you know the idea
is though i got to eat a hoagie a day
yeah yeah all right what what could we
do here what could be the thing that you
win
is it something i got to do no because i
i should i don't want to be involved in
this
because you're going to eat it for 30
days but you can't mess up like what if
you
like have a busy day and you forget you
have to go to the store and buy a hoagie
you have to if you're home you don't
need the house you got to make a hoagie
if there's like a snowstorm and you
can't get out
i understand now hey i just watched the
mayor of east town and i'm all up on my
philly speak
here's the problem though it's only you
got to do only
it's hard to find those hoagie rolls in
the store
in good quality it's easier to find a
kaiser roll
but the kaizerola circle that's a
sandwich that's a roll
i'll give you two kaisers but you don't
want to do that but in philly
a kaiser the most famous local norrish
town sandwich is a zip
and people aren't going to tell you that
doesn't count as a hoagie and it comes
on a kaiser
so this is the problem there's a lot you
can find a hero role in any deli in
manhattan come on
you think you can just find like good
amoroso rolls i'm not doing it with
gross rolls i'm doing it with good rolls
and you get the rolls for my own my own
sandwich shop
yeah but i didn't ask you to eat a
sandwich a day for 30 days i actually
eat a headache oogie i say i can get the
hoagie rolls for my sandwich shop
okay but they're eight inches okay
that's a fair compromise
all right 30 days
i mean it's a little bit of a treat
until a certain point no
i mean honestly it would be a tremendous
treat honestly in my head
i'm like you should i wouldn't want to
do this because when you overthink it
like it's probably not good for me
but just my day day-to-day when you ask
me if i want a hoagie on any given day
i'm like of course i want a hoagie
right so it's really you got to get in
your head
and you really got to just make it right
for yourself and come out of there
actually i want people to be able to i
want the listeners to be able to play
along in real time
i have eight new joey rose's sandwiches
i need to try out
i mean there you go right there between
them they have and they you don't have
so far you're halfway through the month
that's 16. yeah
so what you got to do is have two of
every hoagie you've ever invented two
times
i mean a hoagie event two times right
that'll
cover 32 days because the peanut butter
and jelly one count as a hoagie
see that's what i'm saying i'm gonna say
no it's a hoagie roll with chips on it
peanut butter and jelly tripper that
triple decker
yeah but i could eat peanut butter and
jelly every day for a year that's not
the same as eating a home
you have you've never eaten this peanut
butter and jelly all right
it's a lot that's a lot of rules i'm not
saying i don't want you to [ __ ]
pbj loophole discredit it then that's
fine i want to show you something what
pimp did
pimple went ahead and got the watch the
mccullet
and the who's he watsip okay and there
you go
by lisa m and you and i my friend
are going to try this right now do you
feel like trying yeah let's try it
i will say i only eat a little bit
because of my uh because the hoagie
my chocolate uh thing that i get
you know i get like my chocolate i get
like an hour i get a lactose thing now
with things oh okay chocolate gives it
to me
just i can have a little nibble a thin
layer of chocolate on a bar we'll give
it to you yeah you got a severe case
i mean look you know you want to talk
about my personal life you want to talk
about these candles well
isn't it it's a dairy thing you call it
a chocolate thing that's why it's
through me
oh you have a chocolate thing and then
you point it to like the back of your
mouth
all right that was very very useful i
only assumed someone who knows you
dearly i only
assumed you knew what i was talking
about because we've talked about it at
length at least seven or eight times at
this point
but when you say my chocolate thing and
then point to this area
i'm not like oh his lactose thing you
should have been like because
every time we hang out and i'm like dude
i can't eat that chocolate
no i didn't know you can't eat chocolate
though you couldn't eat ice cream no i
can't eat candy chocolate because of the
lactose thing
all right i can eat chocolate cake and
it's fine i don't understand but my
lactose thing is getting
worse i ate a cheese i ate a polio
string cheese today
and it started giving me a little bit of
a stomachache that's the problem it's
getting worse by the day can i tell you
something
my whole life i went without a lactose
into lactose intolerance then about like
10 15 years ago i got one i had it for a
couple of years it went away
i don't know why i got it and why why it
went away it sucks but
by the way it could be better days ahead
of you somebody else wrote to me
or wrote to us that that uh that there
wasn't our
there was already a what you would call
it sequel called the thingamajig
and i looked it up and it was real and
thingamajig is actually a term like what
you may call it yeah
and it's basically the who's he wants it
except i guess it didn't sell so they
tried they're trying to do this we're
trying to rebrand it and that's where we
are today let me tell you something the
watchmen call it is 230 calories
and the who's he wants it is 250
calories there's also more fat
more sodium more carbs
and they release and more protein
release under the bus here which one you
want to do first babe
the ridge okay you got to go a ridge
first
guys if you have these at home take them
out now
oh and one other brand new piece
want to do a half season you can't do a
half second i can't i gotta do bites
babe
okay very thin
man still so good
peanut butter and caramel mmm or
something
that's something it's delightful
everyone who wanted to hear us chew on
eating on the pod let's see where this
goes now
let's see what if this tops it i swear
if this tops it
i'm not gonna know what to do i'm not
gonna know what to do with myself right
now
you don't once the chocolate doesn't
break and go into the fibers of the
couch
all right i'm sorry no no i don't see
what happened
you see one shot off it's gonna get
embedded into the fibers you can't get
that out
oh look at that don't don't throw it
onto the floor i didn't know what to do
for those of you listening only uh we
broke the candy bar a huge chunk of
chocolate on the couch and joe took a
swipe
at it as if to just knock it on to the
carpet
i didn't know what to do same time this
time okay should i break in case you
want more
yeah okay
okay babe here we go who's he watts one
two three
hmm interesting it's a different texture
a little bit
you see they put that peanut butter
layer on the top
it's wonderful
it's hardcore chocolate though wow that
is it's good it's very good it's good
but it's straight up chocolate
it is straight up chocolate with a thin
layer of peanut butter in there it's
very good though
it's good i don't think it beats the
original family was it beef or rich but
it's very good yeah
well there you have it jury's out i have
a question for you guys yes how long
does a chocolate bar last in your hands
on the street walking around and you buy
yourself a bar
you mean if i open it and eat it yeah
like how long do you savage with it
i'm a gavon as as i say bay ridge
yeah it's like i'm gonna i'm gonna eat
that thing and i try to savor it i'll
take a smaller bite on purpose
i do this trick with orange juice when i
drink it because usually
i gulp down orange juice because i can't
get enough of it but a lot of times they
sell orange juice in like these small
containers like 12 ounces
it goes really fast you know i do a
little trick where i actually govern
my own intake and so if i could normally
drink an orange juice in like
eight gulps i'll make sure i get 24 sips
instead
i'm bad with that and if you get the
taste it does really
swirl it around in your mouth you do
feel almost as satisfied as the gulp of
it
and it lasts a long little tip i'm bad
with that
because i get like especially when i get
mcdonald's breakfast
yeah i i would have to get an extra
juice with it because i always get the
apple juice
and the apple juice is kind of small
it's that little dixie cup for you they
don't have it on top what's up with
apple juice i would
buy extra apple juices because i'm like
i can't control myself you buy this you
you buy a combo
for breakfast and then you get and get
another apple juice i get an extra maybe
sometimes a third apple juice
no because i'm just like it's three
apple juice sometimes it's like that
it's like a little teeny box yeah what
are you getting again you got a
mcgriddle
no you get sausage egg and you're gonna
make this buff with a biscuit
and then i get biscuit or mother meal
muffin i get the sausage muffin with egg
nah
we've already done it i know and then i
get an egg mcmuffin they can i get
cheese
sometimes an extra hash brown and then i
get extra apple juices
that sounds insane that sounds like way
too much it's just right to be honest
with you
so you're eating you're eating two
sandwiches a muffin and three apple
juices
no no muffin mcmuffin
two eggs i'm eating a sausage egg
mcmuffin yeah
a regular egg mcmuffin that's two what's
a regular egg mcmuffin
the ham egg and cheese okay and then i
get a hat and then it comes with a hash
brown the meal
sometimes i'll get a bonus hash brown
you call it a bonus it's not that much
it's like eating two burgers in like a
large fry
okay that's really all it is okay not
even that it's sandwiches and then three
apple juices yeah it's usually two i'm
saying
there's been times when i've gone for a
third because i'm like you know
that's way worse than a goddamn hoagie a
day man i'm not doing it every day you
know you can get it anytime now you know
this of course you know this
yes breakfast anytime do you exercise
that option
never why because i only want it in the
morning
and i barely want breakfast in the
morning never have breakfast at dinner
i always hate it when my mom pulled that
when i was a kid it really
pissed me don't feel like it was a
welcome curveball you took your mom to
task for it you think she was being lazy
i don't think she was being lazy i think
she was being frugal
when it was like hey we're running low
on food and we're not gonna waste
anything so let's do breakfast for
dinner
i mean there were times where i had a
heart too horrible hard-boiled eggs for
dinner
because because you were being frugal
actually i guess
pancakes didn't upset me that much at
dinner time
pancakes for dinner's not being frugal
that's just what that's
breakfast for dinner telling me i know
but i was talking like eggs
you're telling me your mom was like you
want a pancake it's for dinner and
knocks for 90 nights
i know but as a child you were
discerning
you you overlooked the fact that you
were gonna be able to have pancakes for
dinner and you were like
quit being frugal mom no no i'm saying i
don't think i minded it when it was
pancakes and bacon
okay when it was like a different kind
of breakfast for dinner i i was not into
it
i'm never look i've never been a big
breakfast guy i have been a dinner guy
my whole
lunch and dinner guy my whole life when
we would go to the smorgasbord
when we were kids uh my cousins couldn't
wait to get through the meal you mean
like a buffet yeah my cousins couldn't
wait to get to the meal so they could go
to the all you could eat ice cream bar
sure and i would ask to go back to the
get more fried chicken wings that's what
i wanted i didn't care about the ice
cream
i really i rarely hear people refer to
the buffet experience as well when we
would go up to the smorgasbord that's
what i called it when we were growing up
well anyways i
suppose it is a smorgasbord what's the
etymology of the word smorgasbord but
let me go right back to that
oh let's see pimp spell this one this
thing oh my god
hold on tim if you go back hold on do
not
click a thing do not move
do not you need to lie still like i'm
inside you and i'm gonna get you
pregnant if you move right now
[Laughter]
you spelled it more more i guess board
smorgasbord the pimp way
[Music]
m-o-r-e-g-e-s-b-o-a-r-d
holy i like google spell for me oh wait
you might have only missed like
you forgot an s up there up top let's
see what it is
that's the problem do you hear what he
just said i let google spell for me this
is why you you get an email from a
grown professional now yeah and it
doesn't have punctuation it's ridiculous
yeah he's coming down on you
also did you notice my email's the
homeless pimp
they're not expecting much i'm saying
like from an office worker
good smorgasbord the board and
smorgasbord is b-o-r-d i would have
spelled that wrong
s'more gas board s-m-o-r-g-a-s-b-o-r-d
if you spelled it differently that i bet
you most people spelled that wrong
a buffet offering say it smorgasbord
a buffet offering a variety of hot and
cold meats salads hors d'oeuvres etc
a wide range of something a variety now
do you think
that's where where to come from there
you go
babe it's come to me in any old buffet
offering uh a choice of foods
in the united states term originated in
sweden
do you think that's why do you think
that's why s'mores are called s'mores
because it's a play on smorgasbord
because it's like a bunch of different
things together um
i think it's some more i think it's like
uh a stylized give me some more
okay that's what i thought it was yeah
it is you're right
right yeah you're right okay so then go
back to the
the last page i just want to read what
that said uh it's from
sweden roots are found in the upper
class of 14th century sweden where a
small spread
of bread butter and cheese was offered
before meal time
okay wow so so the swedes came up with
the annie pasta and not the italians
were racist to say swedes no i don't i
don't think so
i don't know although although i really
don't know what's what's
pejorative or derogatory today or not i
get confused
you know i i'm that's why i i i think
pejorative almost sounded like a
bad word to me i know sweet everything
sounds swedish
sweet it's the swedes can't be can't be
wrong right
uh i wouldn't bank on that uh swedish if
you're swedish and listening to this
tell us if calling you swedes uh
unintentionally
is uh something that offended you okay
cancelled what if this is what we got i
think me going further to paradise it
was the swedish chef was like more would
have heard a thing that bird or hate you
what are you talking about he really
speaking sweet
talk about things from that era that
don't play these days
i wouldn't be surprised if swedish chef
was under fire they just canceled pepe
le pew yeah
uh the swedish chef all he wanted to do
was come in and
cook for you right now i know but
the uh i what if this is why we got
cancer what about that snl
that would that be the greatest one
before you go on with your thoughts
swedes yeah
my thought no if we got canceled for
saying sweet yeah i don't know any
swedish words do you
feel robin it was the running gag on the
golden girls and i love the golden girls
that's one of my top five sitcoms of all
time
but i i hated the rose swedish jokes
it got like really cool from mount olaf
saint olaf
say no i liked when she talked about how
backwards her town was that always made
me laugh yeah but i hate it when they
would always be like
when she would always be like we called
it gerferg
like i was like yeah uh god bless
shout out um betty white still
still going god bless her yeah i know
right man
i i don't see her a lot
lately and i hope she's a year-long
pandemic and she's a
107 years old maybe she laid low for a
while
yeah she's 99 dude yeah god bless you
what a treasure yeah that's amazing yeah
that's amazing
i hope i go that long although i've
come nowhere near any of the success she
saw by my age
so if i'm that old i'm probably going to
be in a lot of financial straits
what do you think factors into her being
able to achieve 99 was that written in
the books
is that something in her dna where it's
like it didn't i mean honestly if she
smoked and ate hoagies every day
maybe she would go sooner but like do
you think like
like it was predetermined by her genetic
makeup that she might have lived that
long
or do you think genuinely honestly you
know what i think has
a lot to do with it i think she is
genuinely positive
uh and i think she really does always
see the
glass as half full and look at this she
would run a mile every morning up until
covid
wait no way is that true at 98 years old
she was running a mile
every morning okay but still
pimp used air quotes but still i don't
walk a mile every day
not like let me walk this mile i might
get my steps in
wow she um you know she uh
i think like that genuine genuine pot
it's apparently why bea
arthur didn't kinda didn't like her all
the time was because she was so positive
about everything
really yeah well if negativity is a sign
that you're not going to live long we
need to all
reassess she went pretty long didn't she
be went into her 80s
how tall was b was she like six eight
probably six she was over six i love
that pip had the right golden girls
because she couldn't even begin to think
of how to spell bea
arthur let's go to b's wicked
wikipedia oh look at that
nailed it pimp i watched golden girls oh
all right all right
pimp nailed it beautiful yeah uh she was
shout out scroll down scroll down to a
picture under the picture
there it is does the math 486 i'd still
like to trade in
i like to trade in i'm a b arthur type
bernice was her name i didn't know that
yeah oh wow
if you had to have a uh she was a staff
sergeant
how about that wow
ah she was in work she was she was
awarded a medal in world war one
world war ii oh i don't have my glasses
on yeah yeah yeah
now that would yeah that makes sense i'm
like damn
so wow okay god bless so back to the
food talk another thing we thought we
were gonna we were gonna
talk about this week was the record yeah
we got it
we do have it i do have some bad news
pertaining to it though let's go to it
shouts out to
pimp what is the handle of the very
lovely person that made this again
uh i can't see this lotus uh you can
follow
us at get lotus a at symbol g-e-t
l-o-t-i-s on uh in
on twitter uh thank you so much for
putting in that that
work for us that was such a cool thing
yeah lotus is a super fan a whole chart
we'll put it up on the screen here she
made this chart we asked like who's
ahead where what's the score
and lotus made one for us which is
amazing uh sal
is currently winning by two this is not
the user-friendly
can you what about the graphic that she
oh wow that she made a margin thing as
well yeah
so that's the percentage margin so we're
that close
so the margins are that close so there's
only a two percent difference in
cumulative margin disparities i don't
know what that means what you just said
but so like if i win no there's a four
percent difference because you're
negative your margin is negative two my
margin is
positive 2.
are you sure about that or then i don't
know how that works
but anyway where you sal is too ahead
percentage points that means nothing oh
actually wait no that's wrong
she tell after the current wins you're
also your margin is also higher
by 14 and 150 that's right be real by
0.4
that's right it is your other win took
you past my 2
so what i'm saying is she's basically
okay so if you win 60 40 right
it's basically that means you win you
were plus 10 if you win 60 40.
because 50 is the baseline right or sh
if you win 60 40 you plus 20.
she's doing it by 50 so she's saying you
got
10 more people than half that's how
she's doing it so you see like right
there where it says like
french fries 75 beat on your rings 75 to
25 oh no she did fix that
she did put 50. oh someone called that's
what it was
someone corrected her on that and that's
why she changed it
because the margins were different okay
okay so
you're telling me that out of if you add
up all 100 percentages
throughout all 27 episodes
that we're as close as a difference of
of a half a percentage difference away
in votes
so i don't know what you're talking
about the margin
following any of it all i know is this i
didn't feel like doing this
so somebody else did it okay now you're
taking me through all the things i
didn't want to do
you put up her graph her graphic that
she had yeah that's easier can you blow
it up a little bit
that is the old one your margin you have
a higher
percentage margin than me and you're
ahead by two that's it that's it
now blow that up
okay do you want do you see what i'm
saying though buddy like for example
everything bagel okay
62 to 38 percentage was that win
so how is the margin 64 to 36
yeah i don't get how she's doing these
margins oh she did okay
so she's judging from 50 so for example
french is an easy round one right french
fries versus onion rings french fries
won
75 to 25 percent so she's saying the
margin
is 25 because 25 will get us dead even
i don't understand and i don't want to
think about it
i don't care but it's a
telling statistic though that's great
you're winning that's the only thing
that's
not understanding cumulatively with all
your percentages added up and all my
percentages added up
until for 26 episodes we are less than a
half percentage point difference
between us that is how it's one and a
half percent
mother i'm over this myself now there's
one and a half percent if you look at
the spreadsheet all right
your appointment that's nothing i know
but you have hundreds of percentages
more wins you're 14 to 12.
yes that part i understand right i don't
think you're
i don't think you're getting how cool of
a statistic the margin difference is
i mean it just sounds like it shows you
stuff to
this way if i if i was winning you know
20 20 wins to 10 wins
but our margins were that close it
that's how big
of how like how close of look i forget
it so we're both great at this
we're doing it's very close okay that's
all you had to say
very close that's all you had to say uh
but look 14
12 and 11 to 12 14 before we move on to
today's battle
a bit of bad news joe i'm gonna talk
about magic spoon and if you listen to
the podcast
you are no stranger to magic spoon but
if you're listening for the first time
let us tell you about magic spoon
it is cereal like we had him with
children but you could eat it again now
as adults yes
right yes i mean it comes in like eight
flavors it's cinnamon it's blueberry
it's honey nut they change it up all the
time you got peanut butter
frosted but the thing is it's not loaded
with sugar and carbs it's not terrible
for you
there's zero grams of sugar that's
insane there's 13 to 14 grams of protein
which is like eating turkey and uh
it's only four net grams of carbs so
it's like keto friendly
it's 140 calories a serving it's gluten
free grain free
soy free low carb gmo free you ever
watch like shark tank
and someone comes in with a hot new
product that's a market disruptor and
they go why is yours different and they
just go down this list
of all these things people are now
health conscious they're ecologically
cons
is that a word ecologically ecologically
they're ecologically conscious
this checks all the boxes what i like
about uh magic spoon is that i feel that
it's
it's it's almost like when you used to
watch movies about the future when you
were little
and there'd be like a ridiculous like
thing in the movie where it'd be like
cigarettes are good for you
right it turns out magic spoon is doing
that magic thing
it's it's like you're watching the movie
you're watching robocop 6
and everybody's eating cereal three
times a day and they're going it's
actually not bad for you
right we were wrong we were in the
future we were cereal's healthy
we did it uh you can build your own box
as sal said they have an assortment of
flavors they don't have honey nut you
just threw that in they had it at one
point i think
they did have it they did oh okay
they're always they're always
okay rotating flavors which is awesome i
take it back they had honey nut
we want you to go to magicspoon.com
taste buds you're gonna grab a custom
bundle of cereal there you could try
today
you can build your own box whatever
flavors you like and be sure you use our
promo code
taste buds at checkout you're going to
save yourself five bucks off your order
that's magicspoon.com tastebuds use the
promo code
taste buds to save five bucks and this
company is so confident in their product
it's backed by a 100 happiness guarantee
so if you don't like
the magic spoon cereal for any reason i
don't know why you wouldn't
they will refund your money no questions
asked so go to magicspoon.com
tastebuds use the promo code taste buds
get five bucks off thank you magic spoon
for sponsoring us
sal i know you're a lot like me and
you're into a personal care routine
oh yeah oh you don't even understand
what i do i exfoliate i use toner
i use uh i use all sorts of creams and
lotions
i think that's great and people have
different types of plans
people have self-care babes self-care
plans people have two-step plans people
with three-step plans
i want to let's talk about hawthorne one
of our newer sponsors
uh they're gonna help you get the most
out of your personal care routine
they got shampoos body washes hand soaps
luxurious
sandalwood shaving gel all made without
sulfates parabens and other harsh
chemicals
again what makes companies stand out uh
well i'll tell you what makes this
company stand out
i got a box of this stuff in the mail a
week ago i'm so excited
i love it you take little quiz on their
website okay and they ask me stuff
like you know how do you how do you uh
uh
what's your favorite brand of cologne
and uh how often are you doing a facial
i love taking little quiz you know that
kind of stuff
and you start to answer the questions
little by little right yeah
and they say okay here's your bundle
it's called an essentials bundle and
it's these products they're all tailored
to you and your body type and your
lifestyle
it's fun i like that you're really
taking the work out of it yeah
i got a specific shampoo that was made
for me i got a specific facial wash that
was meant for me
i got a specific deodorant and it's all
according to like what you focus on in
your self-care
and then what's what sense and and what
kind of like
the deodorant question they'll be like
are you a heavy sweater or are you
somebody that wants to stay dry do you
not mind a little bit of perspiration
they ask you very specific questions
and i got a box of all this stuff
including two
two bottles of cologne once his work one
says play
i've bought some fine clothing i've
bought some fine colognes in my day
these things smell so good really i'm
telling you
wow i'm telling you i mean if you throw
cologne on you you're unstoppable i'm
unstoppable
take hawthorne's quiz today and get
started on your personalized self-care
routine
by going to hawthorne.com that's
h-a-w-t-h-o-r-n-e
dot c-o and use our promo code taste
buds
to get 10 off your first purchase that's
h-a-w-t-h-o-r-n-e dot c-o-o
promo code tastebuds hawthorne.co promo
code tastebudge you got to try it what
do you have to lose you got to it's
awesome
27 episodes is the halfway point to 52.
that's
right dead half right now right now and
i have a two win lead
yes okay you can go anywhere could go
anywhere with it but i got bad news
because i looked it up last night is
there is a spoiler
the sugar-free hair bros are off to
market you can't find them anymore
that's why we couldn't find them last
week in the store they had 10 guys
i looked on amazon i looked i googled i
went to google shopping you can't find
these things they're
gone oh because they probably have to
pull them because everybody so we got to
figure out a different thing
another thing we gotta do how do you win
and how you lose
before any fans suggest make joe eat ice
cream if he loses i'm not doing that
because it is not i'll deal with a [ __ ]
your pants thing
i'm not dealing with a uh allergic
reaction vomit thing like that all right
well the good news is we have 27 weeks
to figure out what's going to replace
the hair sugar-free gummies so let's
let's we'll also put that to the fans we
want to hear about some ideas for the
30-day hoagie challenge and we want to
hear some ideas about
what the penalty should be if you lose
uh if you i would eat the bird a bird's
heart oh
no you won't a hundred i've eaten heart
i would do it again i've eaten rocky
mountain oysters which are
ball uh goat nuts i've eaten them
i've eaten them they had them in a bar i
was like i'll try it like let me try it
you ever see a funny farm with chevy
chase yeah but she's like what
you broke the record 100 sheep balls
yeah yeah yeah that's a funny movie it's
great it's an underrated comedy from the
80s funny farm
all right let's get moving to the to the
battle for today lobster roll versus
crab cake
it's a great summer battle i know and
today is june
1st record it happy pride
drops next week but we're recording on
june 1st yeah it feels
i don't care anybody says june 1st first
day summer i agree i actually completely
agree yeah
yeah so uh happy pride
and happy summer and
happy seafood what you taking
well we discussed earlier i will be
taking the crab cake
and i will be taking the lobster roll
uh i've got a lot to say i i can you can
do
please please go let's get right into
this now lobster
is not only my dad call it the cockroach
of the ocean no
lobster is not only my favorite seafood
of all time
oh okay it is arguably
it could be my favorite food of all time
it is definitely a contender as is
the team i will be fighting against in
another upcoming battle
however there is no
food i order less in my life
than a lobster roll
what please does not bring you
mayonnaise
into the equation with the delectable
meat of the lobster
is not only disgusting but disgraceful
and disrespectful to the quality of that
meat
you're getting a hot dog amount of
lobster meat
they're charging you 27 i
hate this sandwich any way you can slice
it
the lobster roll disgusts me i'm
offended by it
while i like all versions of a lobster
roll there are two prominent versions
one is a butter poached which is the
best thing that my tongue has ever
licked
okay so yeah i want you to go you can't
just just argue against the mayonnaise
mix
listen i love a butter poached lobster
roll you try and find one
because i've looked everywhere every
time i see lobster
places you can get that but every time i
see lobster on the menu i go
is this the mayonnaise kind of oh yeah
it's the mayonnaise one yeah those
people suck but
my favorite lobster roll and i'll shout
it out right now ed's lobster bar on
spring street in soho
ed mcfarland is a chef he's one of my
childhood friends
i am not just saying this i get lobster
rolls everywhere i go
he has a full menu of all lobster items
and his lobster roll
is a knock down drag out blow your bees
off lobster rolls how much we talk
it's uh it's in the high 20s maybe low
30s but it's not
an everyday thing you treat yourself
it's like a pound and a half of meat on
that thing
apparently it's like a pound you're
getting a pound it's like a it's a lot
you went from a pound to a pound on a
split top butter roll that he soaks in
the butter
he puts it in with delicious homemade
fries and his homemade pickles
with vinegar 17. at the truck
to 40 with tax and tip well that's not
his spot though right no it's not his
fault
well you could also go to like something
like a luke's which is making lobster
rolls more accessible and those are like
18 bucks
and they're not bad they're not heads
but they're not bad
i'll try it yeah you got we'll go
together we'll go together someday
but lobster well okay lobster lobsters
pee out of their faces apparently
they have urine release nozzles right
under their eyes and they urinate in
each other's faces as a way of
communicating
either when fighting or mating how do
you know which what the urine is meant
for
if i piss on your face how do you know
if i want to punch you i have sex you
know you got pissed coming out of your
eyes is it is it
no matter what happens is it that bad at
that point
so look here's the thing the rival
shellfish the rival crustacean to the
lobster
is the crab yeah yeah undoubtedly
yeah undoubtedly if we're comparing just
i love crab now i love alaskan king crab
i love cocktail sauce i
but honestly when you have a crab cake
you take that cocktail we're not doing
crab versus lobster we're doing a
lobster roll versus crab cake
so and you gotta and what you have to do
at that point in my opinion
is go on average and on average a
lobster roll
is a man easy overpriced disgusting mess
and on average a crab cake you're at
least when it's
still bready getting some wonderful crab
flavor
and an enjoyable bread treat at its best
it's all crab meat just fused together
with minor
amounts of bread let's go line by line
the meat
lobster meat is better than crab meat in
my opinion i love crab meat
but lobster meat is sweeter and i like
it better especially when it's cooked
the right way what about a shredded crab
meat and what about the variety of crab
meats you can get they all have
different flavors
let's just go back to what i was saying
okay yeah go ahead
my favorite version of a lobster roll is
a butter poached butter
is the number one ingredient in anything
that you think that you love how it
tastes even if you get a burger
the bun is soaked in butter every place
cooks with butter even if you don't
realize it
you go to a restaurant if you read
kitchen confidential
you'll know that most things in
restaurants that you think are delicious
are
absolutely soaked in butter butter is
like jesus's ingredient
right a lobster poached
roll with the roll grilled and soaked in
butter to a golden brown a split top
butter roll
you're getting with some diced celery a
couple of you get
specific with the split top butter roll
thing because
you well most places put it in some type
of toasted
buttered bread i've
rarely seen that what do you eat and
have
i don't eat them because they look like
[ __ ] because they come out looks like
they'll work like a split top
they look like a little like a little
claw that's pinker than like the other
mean it's like a
it's gorgeous it's gorgeous you have a
look at like you have a look at jumbo
lum crab
it just looks like like just balls of
little white balls
it's beautiful it's pristine white with
hints of pink and red and it's
gorgeous and you put you put
lump crab meat that's like eating
delicious big league chew
you put that into your mouth dude and
it's so good
it's so what kind of parallel is that
you're not doing yourself a favor there
it's strings
of of a delicious thing no joe
like big league chew here's the thing a
lobster roll when you have a lobster
roll it's an event
okay it's like when people go you want
to go for sushi you know what i mean
people like it's like oh let's go for
lobster rolls it's like
you base the whole trip around the
anticipation
of having a lobster roll it's not an
everyday thing it's a little expensive
but when you go for lobsters when you
want one you go you know what i haven't
had in a while you know what i really
want a lobster roll
crab cake let's go for it no i don't go
you know what i haven't had in a while
crab cake is on every single menu
already crab cake is on every menu you
go you want to break it down
anything except a diner you want a grape
cake is it that appetizer you want to
break it down
you want to break down delicious blow by
delicious blow let's just break down the
names of these things
crab cake two amazing words right next
to each other
you hear those words you think of two
great things you think a crab meat and
you think a cake
and boy oh boy does the crab cake
deliver on both fronts when you hear
lobster roll
roll it sounds disgusting
it sounds disgusting grasping at
phonetics no
i'm not grasping you're hooked now on
phonics
you are
you think of all these terrible things
esther roll
she's great listen to me can i tell you
something about a crab cake i like crabs
i like crab cakes i will tell you
something
the best crab cake i've ever had in my
life
is as good as like the top 50 crab cakes
i've ever had in my life
they haven't that's feelings i swear to
god both bad crab cake
that's both all i'm saying is when you
have a good crab cake it is in the same
exact bucket as
every other good guy you can't this is
killing it's like okay this is okay
you're blowing you're blowing past my
very valid argument
that a wonderful butter poached lobster
roll and this comes up a lot on this
show
and i i want to really point this out
you're blowing past the argument where
i'm agreeing with you
that a butter poached lobster roll is
wonderful magnificent and delicious and
i'd love to eat it all day long
however that is not the average type of
lobster roll you're dealing with and you
have to take into account
what you're going to get on average and
on average a lobster roll sucks
it's cold lobster meat and mayonnaise
with like chives and [ __ ] chopped into
it
and it's put onto a very lackluster roll
it's very under why is the wrong
black luster because you you use that
adjective no why is the role
i'm saying because most places have a
lackluster role and on top of it
they overcharge you for something that
is not filled you're getting overcharged
like a
mother on the crab cake by far you get
to go don't go down there
with me joe don't go down this road with
me because i will tell you right now the
best lobster roll is i'm staring you
right now
a million times not 10 not 100 out of
100 not 10 out of 10.
a million times out of a million times
the best lobster roll is better than the
best crab cake a crab cake
has a ceiling telling me i understand
but i'm dealing in averages here and i'm
saying on average the average
the average crab cake is better than the
last you go into any restaurant that's
worth its salt anyone you could probably
take pick
one every block in manhattan one every
block
they will have a crab cake on the
appetizer menu a hundred percent
you order that crab cake if it is not
terrible it is the same as every other
crab cake
the best crab cake is as good as any
crab cake that is not
bad do you want to see what i'm saying
it tastes there's one way to make it
that's the other thing i like that you
can get mayo or butter poached if you
want
you could pick a lobster roll based on
your mood based on your preferences
i i like i like to switch it up every
once in a while okay i prefer butter but
i'll eat mayo
you're taking my lobster roll
here's what i like about a crab cake you
can also have a crab cake sandwich
so why don't we talk about a crab cake
sam terrible terrible oh stop it
terrible stuff
and i like crab cakes and i like
sandwiches it's a dry
weird thing it does not try you put a
wonderful piece
of sauce on it oh don't get me started
on
tartar sauce tartar sauce you want to
talk about mayo
not not not you don't like the mayo on
the lobster roll but you like
what's tartar sauce made of pull that
[ __ ] off course it's got some mayo in it
tartar sausage
isn't the only time i'll ever have a
little bit
dip a fish and chip in it but then i'll
open it i love it
i love tarte okay okay let's let's talk
hypocrite okay right now there is a
difference
you keep attributing disgusting mayo to
a lobster roll
i like mayo i don't like it i don't like
my fish drenched in it that's what i'm
saying you're saying you want to dip
your cream
sauce you're telling me you think it's
the same thing to
mash the fish into a bowl of mayonnaise
as it is to put a thin spreading on the
top of the don't even tell me you just
did it out of one of the packets that is
so
nice no i'm saying you put a thin layer
across the top
squeezing you want to have tartar
packets that's gross
you're out of your pocket starter
packets are cleaning your mind joe ever
since i was a child it has been my dream
to curse someone out in fluent german
i tried my friend i tried in high school
i took two years of spanish in high
school almost failed both times
i think i passed the second year because
i made a pinata
you almost failed both times she let me
slide because i cuz i made a pinata
so um you passed by there you go
that means something a little bit like
babel
is the world's number one selling
language at learning app it's addictive
it's fun and easy
it's a way to learn a new language i'm
always trying to better myself and i
always say
oh i'm gonna like buy some software you
know to take all those courses or i'm
gonna go
i had a friend of mine that actually
went to actual in-person spanish classes
spanish language class
this is an app form in like bite-sized
15-minute lessons it's an easy way to
learn language on the go
can i tell you that i love the 15-minute
lessons and i don't say this to be funny
yeah
i like bettering myself but i do like to
put a cap on it that's right
i don't like to spend a ton of time
bettering myself i love that you can do
these 15
minute lessons as you said on the go on
the go designs
of the courses are really based in
practical real world
world conversations they're giving you
stuff you can use exactly right
yes and they have everything they have
spanish french italian germans 14
languages
uh it was created by a hundred over a
hundred language experts
and it's scientifically proven to be
effective
um so this is what i want you to do i i
swear to god i'm going to really learn
how to i'm going to curse you out in
german soon
why me why do you want to curse me so
they could watch on the show
yeah well all right well i'll but yeah
all right fine then i won't curse him
out in jerusalem
a lot of angry listeners all right all
right that's fine you want to get a
purchase for three months of babel
when you go to babel through our offer
that you're getting through us you're
gonna do a three-month purchase you're
gonna buy yourself three months and
they're gonna match it
an additional three months for free okay
so that means you're getting six months
for the price of a three-month
subscription all you got to do is go to
babel.com and use the promo code taste
buds
that's ba
promo code taste buds and you're gonna
get
six months for the price of three babel
language for life uh look folks
it's summer as you know from these
summery themes we're doing in the food
battles
over the last couple weeks uh and i'll
tell you this i got plans this summer
i'm beaching it i'm boarding it oh oh
i'm skating it oh i'm biking it's a joe
derosa's summer baby
and when i'm doing those things i want
my tunes with me yes
and i want my tunes with me in an easy
way in a convenient way in a comfortable
way
and in an affordable way you're talking
raycon aren't you what else would i be
talking about talking raycon raycon with
us from the beginning
yeah that's true a pair of raycon
wireless earbuds in your ears can make
all the difference
crisp powerful beats and you know that's
what you want
at half the price of all the premium
motorboats a lot of times people getting
you have to see what the headphone
market now is exploding
it's exploding with the head i swear and
and everyone's competing and it just
seems like
they're really all very freaking
expensive they are i mean
like 500 bucks for headphones they are
and it bothers me because it becomes
and this is true this really bothers me
the headphones thing
becomes a weird status competition
where like if you don't have the
wireless earbud blu-ray thingies
or the whatever they'll look like their
sound
yeah it's like oh it's like all of a
sudden like you're not you're not like
as cool as everybody knows trendy is
what and it's like you know what
you shouldn't have most of them because
most of them are a rip-off
you're not getting better sound quality
and they're charging you way too much
because it's got
an insignia on it that you think is
going to make you look cool to anybody
else
when you're walking down the street or
ride in the subway or whatever it is
and that's the beautiful thing with
raycon it's affordable
they work they're easy to sync with your
uh
device so easy 24-hour battery life
great portability
you can take them anywhere they stay in
your ears your little compact charging
case
that's great so raycon's offering you 15
off of all of their products uh and
here's what you've got to do to get it
you go to buy raycon.com
tastebuds that's by raycon.com
taste buds you're going to get 15 off
your entire raicon order
such a good deal just go grab a pair and
a spare yeah
50 off for you as long as you go to buy
r-a-y-c-o-n.com slash
taste buds try them out let us uh know
what you think about them barter sauce
is gross dude what else do you have
tartar sauce with by the way
what else do you have tartar sauce with
breaded clams clam strips
oh i don't i just don't like it why you
don't have to like fried fish
you don't have to like it pal it goes on
my sandwich not yours
sauce is uh is mostly mayonnaise it's
mayo and you and here you are [ __ ]
i like it mayonnaise i don't like
lobster soaked in mayonnaise
so have a butter poached you can't get a
butter potion most places yes you can no
you can't you're saying that shall oh by
the way
and you want to talk about any
restaurant you walk into with the crab
cakes
go to any any any place that even
serves one craft beer in brooklyn or
manhattan they got oysters and lobster
rolls on that menu you're full of trust
me this crab cake trust me
it's it's crab cakes on every goddamn
mini dude every steakhouse
every every single meal salmon
steakhouses that aren't
all over and i'll tell you they did the
exact same thing
i like a crab cake but i ever seen
lobster rolls on the steakhouse menu
because they're [ __ ]
no you surf and turf if you get the
lobster on it so i'm not going to put it
in a roll they don't [ __ ]
up that's what they're always aren't
[ __ ] let's just keep that you can also
get crab legs
lobster rolls of [ __ ] now you just said
you just said the ones that you get most
of the time
suck which is the meal if you let me
make a point here okay
i order and eat lobster uh crab cakes
okay i order and eat them all the time
they're pretty good if i'm in the mood
for it and someone makes one deliciously
all it is
is thick golden brown chunks of the crab
in it
but you eat it it tells me you've never
had the right kind of lobster roll
because it's a good
i'm sorry a good crab cake because a
good crab cake has
has stringy crab
i've had a billion crab cakes in my life
i'm telling you
the where's the best crab cake ever had
can you tell me no you can't
because they all meld together because
once you kind of make it good enough
that's how they all taste you have a
friend who has this lobster roll house
and you know that he did i've tried
let's let's say i've tried 50 lobster
rolls from 50 different establishments
i can't tell you great i'll tell you
where to get girls i can tell you good
terrible nobody
where comedy seller olive tree cafe it's
okay they have a wonder they make it
right oh no
i hope they're not listening to this
there goes your sleep lesson
i'm not saying i'm saying they make it
as good as you can make it that's what
i'm saying no matter what restaurant you
go to you go to a michelin star
restaurant they make a crab cake
it's the same way it's a it's a nice
it's it's cakey
it has big chunks of crab in it it's
golden brown
you dip it in your tart you squeeze a
little lemon on it but you close your
eyes
they all taste and chew they say once
you don't
once you make it good enough it tastes
like you're saying there's no deviation
no one ever no one ever gets inventive
with a crab cake no one's ever like
this is my take on a crab cake uh
crab cake is through and through always
the same exact thing and it always
tastes look at that
look how beautiful they all look and
taste the same
that's what i'm saying like because you
don't not enough
there's tons of personality and that's
why they all taste the same is because
you don't change perfection
there's a way to make a crab cake
there's a way to do it good okay
there's a good way to do a lobster roll
that nobody seems to do ever
only people want to do the low rent [ __ ]
way no you're full of [ __ ] by the way
absolutely craft cake crap has the
personality of a wet noodle
i wrote some notes no lobster roll
didn't
didn't mcdonald's have a lobster at one
point out of here they didn't have a lot
of
crab cakes after all too it just came up
right there right there where where
where where right there
mcdonald's lobster roll experience no
that's not what it
read what it says oh boy
yeah they had a lobster roll thank you
very much once you pull a picture of
that thing up pip
let's let's see if it's a butter base it
was in new orleans
new england for a limited time in 2017.
what do
i care if mcdonald's had a lobster you
just [ __ ] on them having the crab cake
because no you said they had a crab cake
and i just said it came up and they had
both i don't care if they have a crab
cake
i'm not seeing a picture of a crab cake
dude my point look i wrote some notes
today
i wrote some notes look at that oh god
that looks disgusting yeah
of course it does okay ready
all taste the same once you've reached
good level
there's never a deviation i wrote tartar
sauce
you hate you hate deviations on this
show
had i brought up a deviation you would
have gotten mad here's a highlight of my
uh description of a crab cake
i wrote boring af
boring bro no but you know they're
boring
restaurants like to do they go do you
want the entree crab cake
and i'm like the entree crab cake what's
that and you order and it's just
two crab cakes the crab cake was 16
bucks yeah straight crab cake is two
crab cakes with 32 bucks
boring you're throwing two on a plate
i'm eating more you charge me double
savings i'll tell you what i'll tell you
what is there anything better than when
you're at a wedding
or a a christening maybe or any type of
event that might have been
floating around and somebody walks by
with that plate of crab cakes with the
toothpicks
oh it is so exciting i've never seen a
mini lobster roll because i was at an
event never that once in a while i was
at an event
once i was at an event with you that had
them i'm sure you're always that event
would you that had them i wouldn't
no i wouldn't know [ __ ] because i
didn't eat them oh yeah [ __ ]
i'll tell you where we were babe i'll
tell you where we were all right
you tell me i will off camera okay
because it's a
place you went we're not supposed to
talk about it yeah i i i go i
i remember these and i go what is that
egg salad look at them
where the crab cake you're telling me
you're out of fo you're at a you're at
an event
somebody walks by with a mini crab cake
and a and another hors d'oeuvre tray
with a mini lobster roll
right you are don't lie to me look me in
the eyes
you're reaching you're reaching for the
lobster i'm going to say you're going to
take a mini crap
first of all i might take both and the
only way you can only take one
take one crab kicks because i don't know
i don't like the mayonnaise i think it's
gross stop
only talking about the one that you
don't like listen
i wish i could talk about the crab cake
i don't like it i think
but i also think the lobster is robbing
you the lobster roll is robbing you of
the lobster experience
there is nothing like getting a plate
with lobster in the claws
cracking the claws open getting peeling
the meat from the tail
a surface for me every time
crab legs i look like i'm a junkie after
i have slices all over my hands and arms
nuts what are you talking about why
would you now you talk about
missing breaking open the lobster yeah
it's a wonderful experience what are you
talking about though dude
i'm saying okay takes it away from you
true or false
the best lobster roll is definitely
better than the best crab cake
true or false possibly okay that's
that's you not wanting to say true
possible okay
true false but this is sad that's like
true or false at a base level
lobster meat is sweeter and better and
more preferable as good as crab meat is
than grab meat uh i like lobster as i
said in the beginning it's my favorite
but you can't make that argument because
there are so many different types of
quality levels with crab
and there's there there's amazing crap
dungeness crab tastes completely
different than king crab than alaska and
then that
it's come on man i'm telling you right
now that i couldn't tell you
where you should go like let me tell you
something you want a crab cake go to
this place you know why
because crab cakes are everywhere and as
long as you know how to make them you
make them decent enough they all taste
the same
i never you know what i always know what
we're seeing in the mood for a crab cake
right but then when i order it
you know what we're seeing here you know
we're seeing here you know what we're
seeing here
is basically this is the difference in
classes
okay in our society
let me finish i'm a man speaking to the
working man to the blue collar man
i go to the average restaurant crab cake
is not
speaking about a regular food appetizer
it's 20
for a disc uh princess over here
princess volcano floats around in her
little magic cloud
yeah to all the lobster roll restaurants
where they only make them with butter
where they don't make any of the cheap
seafood salad style
moche rolls that i encounter at the
regular people restaurant kind of
argument would it be if i
sat here and argued for imitation
lobster rolls you have imitation crab
imitation crab is just profound then
imitation lies i
told you i don't know imitation
imitation crab
is a gajillion dollar industry are you
nuts through
lobster meat at every supermarket what
are you nuts it's imitation crab meat
they're both
there pollock in it here's the thing
they're not both there they're not both
there they are
i would have finished the one point i
was going to make and then we got to go
to the comments
i understand the argument i even might
agree with it that the best lobster roll
is better than the best crab cake
but that's not what the argument is you
can't debate the best versus the best
look
i could in theory i could in theory
argue oh my god the best beef jerky
is better than the best crab cake
because the best beef jerky is made from
wiagu beef where they massage the cow
and it's seasoned just like this but but
that's not the average
version of it but but you have to argue
let me let me you have to let me say
this the best lobster roll is better
than the best crab cake
the average lobster roll is better than
the average cake and the worst lobster
roll is better than the worst
[ __ ] the worst crab cake is better
that's crap
or worse uh lobster roll joe
every time i'm in the mood for a crab
cake and i order it it tastes exactly
what i was thinking it's going to taste
like
it it satisfied me because i wanted that
taste but i'm never like
this i swear i swear i have skype crib i
like i have them i
have a question i have them where it's a
wonderful experience never eat a crabby
and go
you you got to try this crab cake it
just tastes exactly like a crib you know
what else i like about a crab cake it
can be the main course or it can be the
little appetizer you can leave after all
that's the scam they got you
that's it i told you that the appetizer
meal is on the same menu as the entree
crab cake and all they do is throw
an extra cake on and charge you times
too don't don't don't do that to me
you're not taking all the other apps and
saying oh you want the entree version of
mozzarella 6. it's just 16 mozzarella
sticks
there is no such thing as an entree
mozzarella sticks but that's all
there's no such thing as an entree crab
cake mister it's two appetizers i had it
on mother's day with my mommy
what was it what was it it was two very
large crab cakes yes
so it was great and and guess what one
of them would have been an appetizer
okay
you have the option lobster roll there
is no option they don't offer your
little fancy hors d'oeuvre uh lobster
rolls that's a stupid
argument as as an appetizer
you're in like flynn that's it yeah but
that's a silly argument joe
the reason i can make the argument is
because they do that with crab cakes i
have a standing point here
okay don't do it you can't backtrack and
go well they don't make many lobster
rolls for appetizers yeah but that's
not an argument but i said it's oh it is
an argument let's go to the comments
let's go to the comments i want to see
what everybody has to say
these are both the same thing ocean
garbage okay
okay uh lobster rolls are the best thing
to come out of boston
would you agree yep there
crabs are by far the cooler looking
water alien but i still pick lobster
rolls because my parents taught me the
difference between right and
well pimp slow down the trigger there
the uh i rather have
i rather have an oh so good lobster roll
than something that
has the word cake in it who names it a
cake
having a crab cake is like eating sand
at the park except it's going
except it's to be good expecting it to
be good god expecting to be good the
first time but realizing you just ate
dog [ __ ]
long way to go on that one i i don't
know i actually agree with
vaughn here a crab cake is might be the
worst way to have crab
i i really i really do believe that it
it yes it cakes it together and it puts
a little breading on it
but you but but when you break it apart
you're just eating
hot crab it it's fine i put a little
lemon on that i
avoid the tartar tartar sauce is
disgusting you've made the point
we're in the we're in the comments
you've made the point i don't know joe
i i really don't i didn't like your
argument today you don't have to like it
it's not for you it's not designed for
you designed for the crab cake i thought
it was designed for me
crab cakes are for [ __ ] and joey deez
nuts
they're getting to know us what can i
say you can buy lobster rolls at
mcdonald's that's how [ __ ] they are
end of discussion no you can't yes you
could you can buy them in 2017 for a
limited time at a new england mcdonald's
nobody's talking about the mcdonald's
lobster rolls
even dare do it stop why does mcdonald's
creep into every conversation because
they dare do it
uh lobster roll is so nice but a crab
cake is for middle-aged divorce moms to
make for their kids to make them feel
rich
when in reality she's falling apart on
the inside and then she can place her ex
she needs more money
but goes and buys a purse not all right
uh
the crab cake is a mysterious pile of
disaster
anything could be in there last thing i
want to accidentally discover is a
missing person while i'm eating at joe's
crab shop that's a good point dukey
flyswatter
uh i can tell you right now a lot of
times i'm
we're also when i tell you it's chunks
of beautiful lump crab in a golden brown
cake
that's the best of it but yeah i ever
have a crab cake that has
all extra unidentified stuff in there to
throw in the kitchen sink in there don't
fill the crab cake up because they don't
want to
wear that profit margin with lobster
rolls
there's nothing else to go in there it's
like oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
there's a special place in hell for
anybody that enjoys seafood but if i had
to choose i went crab cake
as i enjoy alliteration uh
i have to go with crab cakes eating a
lobster roll under a hot sun with no
shade is a diarrhea bomb waiting to
happen
this guy i'm not he's picking crab cakes
because if he eats lobster under the hot
sun he has to use the toilet these are
factors
these are factors they are yes
damn it this one was tough because both
are so good but at the end of the day we
all know
that tastes we all know what tastes
better and it's lobster i agree
i said that at the top but not what they
do to it in a crab in a lobster roll
nobody ever said i want crabs in any
context
you know real votes people yes or no is
this something you've heard from someone
i know heard from me or something you
would say yourself
oh dude you want to get some lobster
rolls no never literally never once ever
in my life but you don't hear
dude let's go off of crab cakes no but i
have heard people say i love crab cakes
they're my favorite food i
i live for crab cakes i've heard people
say that i think i honestly
i think this is uh to the crab cake
community and to anyone that is a chef
a cook a line cook a sous chef you know
mickey d's
can you please start doing something
different with the crab cake just
just never mind this whole argument this
is my plea to you try
try give me excite me excite me with the
crack give the crab cake a
facelift please inject something new and
exciting into it
i think this is the winner you can
literally get crab cakes at the 99 cent
store stay in y'all's place for real
[Laughter]
all right let's give that the win uh
retweet the freelance assassins
uh at freelance a-s-s-a-s
number one just meaning the number one
uh there you go let's see you won this
thing i think i'm gonna get it
humble pie let's get that drum roll in
humble pie
seg right here we've got 10 000 votes so
far
what do you think baby you think you're
getting creamed oh
lordy lordy lordy oh my god
that's almost rematch numbers that is
rematch numbers anything under five
holy [ __ ] that wow that is good so close
been there the entire episode really it
has not deviated
10 000 votes we've stayed 51.3
lobster roll takes that w 48.7 now let
me tell you something that's a tough
loss and i'll tell you why
because we just are at the midway point
of season one
at 27 episodes and i'm up by two wins so
to lose by a percentage point
these are tough tough losses yeah right
now yeah i'm aware
all right so now you're up by three
episodes it is you know
it is i almost i almost want to lose
track again though because i don't want
to i don't want to like know the whole
time
i can't live like that i feel like you
do want to live like that i feel like
you're saying this to rub my nose in it
i swear i would i say we refresh uh
later on today and just see where we
stand on this
that is tight and you know what they are
comparable like i said i don't hate crab
cakes
but lobster roll i think is better and i
made the case for that
but really like they both check the same
box when you have a hankering for some
seafood
you know or something like that so after
all this tonight you know what i'm going
to
do
admiral matchups admirable you are going
to go get tonight don't tell me lobster
roll nope
clam strips i said clam strips and i got
it in my head i want fried clam strips
nah i love clam strips once it's fried
it all tastes the same
you don't like clam strips i don't have
them that often but i tell you right now
i
really do not enjoy tartar sauce i love
tartar sauce that's also what i'm gonna
get with it
anyway that's our show that's it i mean
you had a nice app today
we covered some ground we ate a whoosie
watson now what you're gonna call it
uh by the way
shout out to the no press network we hit
a hundred thousand subscribers on
youtube
thank you guys apparently they send you
a little plaque for that yes
um thank you for all your support as we
keep going
uh at to approach now 150 000. yeah and
here's the thing
uh if you like this that's the best way
to help us if you like it
can you tell like tell some friends
about it so they they start uh you know
putting the the audio podcast in their
itunes playlist or
you know uh subscribing to the no
pressure on on youtube the no pressure
network i also want to thank the fans
that are going around to the places that
are kind of
maybe taking it uh from the show
and leaving comments on those fans on
those on the pages of those shows and
things
we really appreciate that and we have a
new
taste buds clips page on youtube you go
to our taste buds clips pimp
taste buds clips and it's basically uh
nuggets and chunks of all the episodes
in like like you know one to three four
minute clips so you could share them or
you could take your favorite
little rant and you could share that
with somebody so you could
digest it easier exactly use a food pun
so thanks everybody stay with us
still love you babe love you too taste
buds
they coming to the mic talking about the
food they hate talking about the food
they like
two fools gonna fight but only one food
can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
them